welcome back to fox and friends shocking
pictures revealing the horrifying
reality of the crisis at the southern
border texas agents on patrol
discovering 40 migrants being hauled in
a trailer while trapped in a metal box
with no means of escape
it comes as an estimated 18 000 illegal
immigrants are set to enter our country
every day when title 42 ends with border
towns fearing the brunt of the influx
the democrat pro tem of uh the mayor of
eagle pass texas yolanda roman joins us
now
uh mayor it's so great to have you on
this morning
before title 42 is listed lifted tell me
just what is the impact right now on
your community
uh good morning rachel um actually i'm
the mayor of pro tem i'm not the mayor
for eagle pass i'm mayor pro temple um
it
it is affecting us in many many ways you
know before that like i said we were
i've said before you know small
community working people you know people
that we go back and forth to the border
because we do have uh family friends
just across the border you know we're
we're right there with the border for
with negras
the way it is going to impact us when if
this um if they put it into
title 42 you know we don't have the
infrastructure we don't have the the
manpower we don't have the facilities
that we are not equipped to to handle
the the influx of people that's gonna
come in i mean uh we're looking at two
three times maybe ten times more than
what we're looking at right now and as
it is right now you know we we can
we can't handle it you know i know
people have said it's been managed
correctly but
i can tell you you know from being here
from seeing it firsthand there's
a lot more that needs to be done has the
federal government offered your
community any resources
uh not that i know um and i guess i
would know you know i assure the council
no we don't have
we do need resources we need um
we need a lot of help we see a lot of
presence you know border patrol um
us um customs we see the um
i'm assuming people that come from army
uh national guard
you know we just had a tragic death from
one of our national guard members that
that uh try to save someone we saw we
see a lot of that presence you know but
even then we don't have the resources
you know they're sent here yes they're
here to help to do a job but we as a
city do not have the resources to take
care of this you know this needs to be
handled in a different way and i think
we all know the answer to that you know
it needs to be
um immigration
um
it's reform has been
waiting too long you know it's a long
overdue more like 40 years overdue you
know so that's the kind of help that we
need yeah well the administration seems
determined to lift
title 42
and you're saying this is going to be an
abs absolutely tragic for your community
what is your community telling you and
what are they worried about most
specifically you know our community some
people understand that it's not us you
know some some people in a community
some people don't understand that it's
not us you know and as as council
members as you know they they keep
calling us and letting us know
why are you letting these people in what
are you taking care of and you know we
need to explain it's not us it doesn't
come from us it's the federal government
and and really there's not much we can
do we're asking um president biden
without due respect to him you know
we're asking to please you know make
sure that there is a stop to this
because um
i mean everyone i'm inviting everyone
from washington to come down to eagle
pants we're a small community but we put
in a lot into the national economy
through our bridges you know we import
and export through mexico so please we
invite invite them you know to come and
see what is happening
to actually come and see it in person
not just through through through tv you
know it is it is not good for the the
immigrant families you know they're
coming in it's not good for us you know
um again our community used to be a very
uh
we're a small and safe community you
know i don't think citizens in eagle
parents and that's their concern i don't
think they feel safe anymore you know
right so there's a there so just really
quick i don't have a lot of time so i
want to make this really clear your your
citizens are not feeling safe they feel
like there's a increase in crime or or
insecurity in in in their feelings of
safety
are your hospitals overrun are your
what other resources are you experienced
or is your community experiencing that
that that concerns them
you know there's there's a lot of uh
concern from the people from the
citizens the hospitals are definitely
overwhelmed because every person that
comes across you know they're being
taken over there again i don't know how
the financial situation had the
resources for the hospital work but
again like any other business i'm sure
they don't have what they need to have
you know it it's just scary as you can
see for us you know it's just it's just
something that definitely needs to be
taken care of you know it's you need to
be
here in our town to be able to see what
we're seeing and what's happening
exactly what that lady did in there you
know people jumping into the river
and and border patrol yeah uh expected
to save them you know that day for
anybody you know so um a lot needs to be
done yeah well they said they were going
to uh come to the border uh the kamala
harris is the tsar she has yet to come i
can feel your frustration i appreciate
you coming on the show today to talk to
us and represent your community
yolanda thank you